eine weitere breaking news große angst
bei schülern und lehrern am lloyd
gymnasium an der grazer straße in
bremerhaven dort fielen am morgen
schüsse die klassen verbarrikadierten
sich sofort in ihren räumen die polizei
und spezialeinsatzkräfte sind mit einem
großaufgebot vor ort und schnell ist
auch klar eine frau ist von einem
bewaffneten täter schwer verletzt worden
sie wird sofort in die klinik gebracht
nach unseren informationen soll das
nicht eine schülerin seien sondern eine
angestellte der schule und der
tatverdächtige wurde bereits
festgenommen sei mit einer armbrust
bewaffnet gewesen seien und dass hier
dieses video es soll die festnahme des
täters zeigen dort auf den boden legen
es scheint so als würde er sich
freiwillig ergeben während um ihn herum
noch passanten vorbei laufen und sich
eher wundern warum der mann dort auf dem
boden liegt neben ihm ist die armbrust
zu erkennen aber dann hört es auch schon
haustein polizeiwagen an die beamten
springen dort dann gleich raus auf dem
boden immer noch der mutmaßliche täter
der die schüsse in der schule in
bremerhaven abgegeben hat und dann
stimmen die beamten zu und nahmen ihn
fest mittlerweile ist wenn
polizeigewahrsam wird verhört die
passanten hier haben es eben gesehen
scheint den ernst der lage noch gar
nicht so richtig erkannt zu haben denn
der was ich hier täter hat sich
anscheinend freiwillig ergeben und
einfach so auf den boden gelegt mitten
in der innenstadt von bremerhaven und
wie nord 24 berichtet hatte eine
schülerin die schüsse als erster gehört
in der schule und die polizei dann
angerufen sie befand sich zu diesem
zeitpunkt auf der toilette und rund 200
schüler die befinden sich derzeit mit
ihren lehrern immer noch in den
klassenräumen
und unser reporter gerd schröder ist
jetzt dort vor ort und zugeschaltet wie
ist die situation jetzt gerade konnten
denn schon einige schüler mittlerweile
das gebäude auch wieder verlassen
nein die schüler sind alle noch im
schulgebäude
inzwischen hat sich die feuerwehr mit
den rettungskräften und auch mit polizei
betreuung ein bisschen umgebaut wie
können wir ganz vorn schauen ist wurde
im hintergrund ein sammelplatz
eingerichtet abseits hier von unserem
presse stellplatz dort wurde ein zelt
aufgebaut und dort hinein sollen die
schüler dann hinein gebracht werden wenn
sie sicher aus dem gebäude geführt
werden und damit sie sich aus dem
gebäude geführt werden können sind
spezialkräfte vom sek hier noch immer
vor ort um das gebäude ist ein grosses
gebäude wirklich intensiv zu durchsuchen
denn erst dann wenn sicher ist dass ist
es sich um kein zweiter täter handelt
der sich möglicherweise noch im gebäude
befindet möchte die schule dann im
grunde das gebäude auch räumen lassen
und dann im grunde werden die schüler zu
dem zelt gebracht und hier intensiv
versorgt intensiv betreut und dort auch
den wartenden eltern übergeben gerrit
wir haben hier gerade ein video gezeigt
dass den angeblich ein amokläufer wenn
man überhaupt von einem amoklauf in
diesem fall ihr sprechen kann das wird
sich alles klären zeigt er ergibt sich
er legt sich auf die straße weißt du
schon mehr zu diesem mann war womöglich
ein schüler dieser schule und was hatte
er geplant
ja da hätte ich die polizei sehr bedeckt
und wen es sich da handelt das haben sie
sich um einen mann das ist sicher und
der ist festgenommen wurden nach der tat
offenbar auf einem gehweg und das video
hat die polizei auch bestätigt jedoch
für die polizei noch nicht sagen um wen
es sich handelt der wurde als ins
polizeipräsidium gebracht und wird dort
jetzt befragt zudem tat um
herauszufinden was die motivlage ist lag
eine beziehungstat vor was ein 1 1 1 1
versuchte amoklauf in der schule der
vielleicht wirklich an der tür
abgewendet werden konnte durch eine
mitarbeiterin das alles ist und
klassischen spekulationen was ein
bisschen verwunderlich ist dass wir
wirklich jetzt schon seit mehreren
stunden hier warten und das schulgebäude
immer noch durchsucht wird ist immer
noch polizeikräfte wir können ganz kurz
mal hier über schwenken also das ist das
schulgebäude hier vom lloyd gymnasium
und wir sehen hier also dass immer noch
polizeikräfte mit blaulicht vor der tür
stehen spezialkräfte sind im gebäude und
das gebäude ist immer noch so dass die
schüler sich in den klassenzimmern
verbarrikadiert haben dh es soll erst
sichergestellt werden dass das gebäude
frei ist dass keine gefahr mehr für die
schüler besteht und das ist eben noch
nicht sicher und deswegen sind schüler
noch im gebäude und werden danach erst
hier hinten heraus geführt
unglaublich was sich dort heute
abgespielt hat gerd werden eben gerade
auch eltern und ihre kinder gesehen die
sich dort weinend in die arme fallen und
dann dieses video der festnahme des
mutmaßlichen täters der sich dort auf
die straße legt während passanten an ihm
vorbeigehen und sind noch gar nicht
richtig verstehen können was sich dort
abspielt und die ist es auch hier sehen
wir dieses video nochmal das müssen wir
noch mal gemeinsam ansehen erlegt sich
dort auf die straße man kann neben ihm
auch noch die armbrust dabei soll es
sich um die waffe handeln erkennen und
passanten verwundert
mutmassliche täter vorbeigehen und dann
auch wenige sekunden später deutlich der
polizeiwagen angerauscht kommt dem
manifest nimmt er derzeit jetzt auf der
wache wird natürlich verhört nennt die
schüler weiterhin ausharren im
schulgebäude das jetzt bewacht ist von
der polizei
aufgenommenen garrett mit einem
augenzeugen mit einem schüler zu
sprechen lasst uns gemeinsam hören was
er zu berichten hatte über diesen
schrecklichen vorfall heute morgen an
der schüler
laufen weg zur schule ich hab dann
natürlich gesehen der ist direkt
aufgefallen dass verschiedene
polizeiautos und feuerwehrwagen vor der
schule stationiert sind und hab dann
direkt mitbekommen das haben wir bis in
hamburg fall ein amoklauf in der schule
stattfinden soll ich hatte das glück
dass ich noch nicht drin war also ich
bin auf jeden fall draußen geblieben
habe mich damit freunden und lehrern
gesammelt und hab dann gewartet was die
leute von drinnen oder vielleicht auch
draußen im erzählen habe keine ahnung
wer es war es wird viel spekuliert dass
sollen schüler oder lehrer gewesen sein
aber die person kennen bundes
dass also die eindrücke von den ersten
augenzeugen von schülern auch die das
gebäude noch rechtzeitig verlassen
konnten immer noch befinden sich viele
schüler in dem gebäude
gerd schröder dankeschön für diesen
moment wir hören uns gleich nochmal und
melden uns dann wieder zurück schauen
aber erst mal auf dieses thema auch
gruselig was sich dort in köln
zugetragen hat eine messerattacke und
das mitten auf einem spielplatz in köln
gehen mehrere männer aufeinander los ein
22-jähriger bricht dann mit
stichverletzungen zusammen und die ärzte
können sein leben nicht mehr retten
etliche streifenwagen stehen auf der
straße mehrere dutzend polizisten
sichern den tatort und befragen zeugen
tödlicher streit in köln unter mehreren
männern ist es am frühen mittwochabend
auf einem spielplatz im kölner stadtteil
ostheim zu einem streit gekommen dabei
wurde ein 22 jähriger mann durch einen
stich in den oberkörper schwer verletzt
trotz sofortiger ärztlicher versorgung
starb er später in einem krankenhaus an
seinen verletzungen
die anwohner sind geschockt es ist schon
krass wie man auch einfach sieht als
seine fremde person trotzdem nimmt das
einen mit deswegen sitzen wir hier auch
einfach so als respekt in gedanken des
verstorbenen der familie ging immer weil
meine freundin hat ihn auch gekannt ich
persönlich nicht aber es ist einfach
zusehen krass zu sehen wie schnell das
leben einfach vorbei es wegen banalen
sag ich jetzt mal kein mensch verdiene
zu stellen eine mordkommission nahm die
ermittlungen auf derzeit fahndet die
polizei mit hochdruck nach dem
flüchtigen täter rund 20 streifenwagen
sind im einsatz
[Musik]